I take full blame for not peeing I ask
my team my family members they didn't
see it and now looking at it so obvious
and we're all these are all just banging
our heads against the wall how did we
miss that
that's Meghan Trainor opening up
exclusively to ET about the controversy
surrounding the music video for her new
single me to Meghan premiered the clip
Monday then pulled it down the same day
saying her waist was heavily retouched
to look smaller
I didn't approve that video and it went
out of the world so I'm embarrassed but
on Tuesday the star revealed to ET that
she did originally approve that
photoshopped video so I approve the
version but I remember we were so
focused on the car scene for a lot of
tapes because they had filters over it
to make it look like a video recording I
said no and I was only really looking at
that part and it was very rough and I
guess I didn't pay enough attention to
the dance scene so that when I thought
out that fans were posting the pictures
of it and I said like why our fans like
photoshopping my waist and then I said
oh guys is that the video and I'm more
upset because I don't watch this whole
music video and song my second single to
be all focused on the photoshopping you
know I want the music to speak for
itself
and for people to listen to the song
instead of look where they photos off to
me but I understand it's still a big
issue